so I've read this amazed me cuz you're
such a dyed-in-the-wool New Yorker than
you actually kind of are warming up to
Los Angeles that's not exactly what I
said I said what I said was I didn't
hate LA as much as I used to and the
reason for that was basically a guide
optimist I'm always looking on the
bright side it I think you Fran the
reason for that was that New York was so
much worse than it used to be that the
contrast was not so great that's all I
meant
so you think New York is worse than oh I
don't think that I know that for a fact
and what has made New York worse
um well Giuliani was one of the people
who may be hurt worse okay well that was
a while ago um Bloomberg his 12-year
reign is it yes New York has gotten more
suburban which was their goal
look I remember the first time Juliana
ran for mayor his ads you know I hardly
know who he was I was not alone in that
he was a prosecutor before that his ads
basically said vote for me and it'll be
1952 again those were his ads for his
first term you know he is just soaked in
nostalgia you know and that is what he
meant when he said you know Obama
doesn't love us you know he doesn't love
the country like we love the country
like we who are his age is even over to
me and it's it's a it's a fanciful
notion what would what do you think is
behind that that Republicans want to go
back to an era the 50s you you said that
where America was really ruled by
socialism we talked about this a few
weeks ago not sure given the economic
policies cuz they were first left over a
new deal but that's not the part they
miss okay that's not growth in this the
part that it you know what is it behind
Julia he's coming cynically racism
you're not allowed to say this we now
live in a society where it's worse to
call someone a racist than to be one you
call a racist racist but I'm not a
racist so he'll call me a racist right
and and they say the most racist things
Ben Stein last year during the campaign
when it was heating up at the end said
Obama is the most racist president we've
ever had and I thought even more than
the 11 who actually owns
Andrew Jackson killed Indians by hand
because they were Indians because yes
just because it's a good thing to do it
was ethnic cleansing well why do you
think that Giuliani said that thing he
said I used it I mean he was the mayor
of a liberal city he used to be sort of
a moderate or PI when Julianne was the
mayor every five minutes and another
black guy was shot in the back it
constantly you know and it was and was
always a different excuse from the cops
he had something his hand I thought it
was a gun it was a candy bar right I had
some tenant that was gun it was a
keychain well that has this arranged and
that's not just but in the entire time
I've lived in New York which has been
many decades that a single unarmed white
person has been shot by the police not
one right not one you think the odds
would be not one so that is the reason
they're shot but query lame that all on
Julie he's gonna say I play mahjong on E
I blame the ones that were shattered
Giuliani which worth the most but my
it
well here's Julie unease quote about he
said today what I said wasn't racism it
couldn't be because Obama had a white
mother a white grandfather he went to
white schools and most of what he
learned was from whites see this is what
the appropriate have against Obama he's
too white a mess he is too white yes
ma'am this is a big problem for Scott
Walker because he said these comments at
a dinner where Scott Walker was trying
to meet and greet with these potential
donors and what did Scott Walker do
afterward he didn't necessarily distance
himself all that much he was just like
oh well Giuliani is free to say how he
thinks and what he feels but I love
America and this isn't really denouncing
what he said and now you're having other
potential GOP candidates kind of towing
a similar line and the problem for all
of them really I mean none of them did a
John Kay agree with it that's the point
is that they agree it's you know it's
not that they are holding back their
criticism they have no criticisms they
agree with it well part of the problem
is is they also have to get through a
primary but after that if they do they
have to get through a general election
so this which they never do and that's
why yeah that's right it is like why did
I get to the general
probably have is their primary and their
general right it's always an issue for
the Conservatives it's because the
lunatics vote in the primary and
Americans vote in the general and that
is why we don't have a but with the
president it's a pretty simple and they
they don't like him because he went to
Harvard he was the editor of the Harvard
whare he is so much like right that that
they resent it okay here's what the
other thing Giuliani said is that it
wasn't racism he said it's socialism or
possibly anti-colonialism yeah what is
that him first of all called me we're
the colonist what we're dense ourselves
and didn't count the Stars
is it colonialism bad I thought we were
all kind of on that page and now it's
bad to be anti-gay yes I I don't
understand that
but you're right who what was George
Washington fighting against yeah they're
not talking about that colonialism what
are they talking they're taught they're
talking about the anti-colonialism of
like Africans Indians you know again
Saudi British that anti-colonialism and
that's bad to them I'm explaining them
to you not Nietzsche was the Republican
primary I know hey I understand but but
it was the British with us we were the
colonies to the British she's not
thinking back quite that far okay yes
yeah but how'd that but how does someone
get sucked into this vortex I mean you
may think that he was a right winger and
he was more than most but he did get
elected mayor of New York City
not by me twice that by babe not right
who I had a chance to vote against three
times right okay despite the two term
limits also a flaming liberal compared
to the rest of the Republican Party my
theory is that Rudy Giuliani has been
out on the speaking circuit that's how
he makes his living okay
that's who you're talking to is the
Republican base what gets the applause
lines Obama's a Kenyan yeah yeah read
that's how you rank I'm a crazy person
I mean Giuliani the only time he's
really been in the news the past few
months is when he said things that were
deemed kind of outrageous he made that
and I think it was in December after the
Eric garner grand jury decision that
white cops wouldn't be in black
neighborhoods if black people weren't
killing each other as much and then I
think in January he made some comment
about Obama and de Blasio stoking anti
police hatred I mean this is now why
he's getting in the news it's not so
much because he's a credible and J also
has an infomercial have you do this but
I agree with you does freely on E has an
infamy reward I don't watch the whole
thing I just see he as you never
mirthful I flip okay I agree with Fran
that there's an undercurrent of racism
that's always recurring it's not an
undercard it's not racism but now it's
out there's something about this I love
America in a way that you can't even
understand I didn't I don't know what
they want is this ID also this
exceptionalism I think that they're like
the Oscar people they want a trophy for
best country America you're the
millionth year in a row you're the best
country at any sight - Reagan again
which is always troubling for me
he won uh Giuliani cited Ronald Reagan
it's a good old Americans um tripled the
national debt matter because after
Michigan